[Aplausos]
[Música]
queridos amigos amigas el eje
franco-alemán continúa liderando europa
pero ahora el equilibrio de poder ha
cambiado angela merkel ha tenido que
lidiar con cuatro presidentes franceses
diferentes sin embargo con la canciller
alemana en retirada las posiciones
francesas se están cobrando cada vez más
fuerza en bruselas el discurso más
incisivo que la unión europea está
adoptando en política exterior es un
ejemplo de toda esa influencia pero
sobre todo es la transición energética
el tema que sitúa en el centro del
debate comunitario la transición
energética y una pregunta clave cómo
demonios lograr que la economía crezca
al tiempo que se acelera la
descarbonización y se reducen las
emisiones de co2
[Música]
y sabéis que mientras se busca una
respuesta el presidente de francia
emmanuel macro hizo este anuncio que
suponía ni más ni menos que romper con
el discurso político imperante en los
últimos años por garante de todos en el
objetivo de la font se podría medir la
provisión eléctrica europea
estando nosotros en particular la
neutrality carbón de 1.005 no sólo por
la economía fuera de diseño o los de la
construcción del reactor nuclear donde
otro tipo
[Música]
y ojo porque el anuncio a pesar de
producirse en un momento de fuertes
tensiones con el precio de la energía ha
resultado sorprendente en buena medida
porque las últimas centrales nucleares
que está construyendo électricité de
france no acarrean más que problemas así
que la pregunta es por qué macrón
apuesta por la energía nuclear es acaso
la nueva generación de centrales
nucleares la solución al cambio
climático y lo que puede resultar
incluso más importante para todos y esta
decisión tendrá consecuencias para el
resto de la unión europea hoy en visual
político vamos a responder a estas
preguntas pero antes antes vamos a ver
un poco de historia
[Música]
a
la potencia nuclear de europa
la relación de francia con la energía
nuclear viene de lejos de muy lejos por
ejemplo fue el científico francés henri
becquerel quien descubrió la
radiactividad y luego las
investigaciones más importantes sobre
sus propiedades les realizaron pierre y
marie curie pero aún habría que esperar
varias décadas para poder aprovechar la
nuclear como una fuente de energía
concretamente hasta
1954 cuando empezó a producir
electricidad la primera central nuclear
del mundo fue en la unión soviética
entonces la energía nuclear parecía el
futuro así que a estos avances se
sumaron pronto el resto de potencias
económicas en el reino unido- los
estados unidos y por supuesto francia
estábamos ya en los años 60 y la mayoría
de los países industrializados habían
construido al menos un reactor
experimental y no sólo eso poco a poco
se fueron desarrollando nuevos reactores
y así es como llegamos al año
1973 para entonces francia tenía en
funcionamiento ocho reactores nucleares
repartidos en cinco centrales diferentes
con otros cinco reactores más en
construcción y entonces entonces llegó
la crisis del petróleo que lo cambió
todo
[Música]
durante la famosa crisis de 1973 el
precio del petróleo se multiplicó por 4
después de que los países árabes
decidieran reducir su producción en ese
momento la mayor parte de la
electricidad de francia un país sin
campos petrolíferos propios era generada
por centrales de fuel frente a poco más
del 5% que procedía de la primera
generación de reactores nucleares
de esta forma la conocida como crisis
del petróleo fue clave para que se
activara el plan messmer en marzo de
1974 francia presentó al mundo el plan
con el que pretendía romper por completo
su dependencia del petróleo extranjero
el objetivo amigos era convertirse en la
mayor potencia nuclear de toda europa
[Música]
este plan para que os hagáis una idea
preveía construir en 10 años 80
reactores de energía nuclear y alcanzar
los 170 reactores para el año 2000 un
plan que debe haberse completado
merecería sin duda todo un capítulo de
megaproyectos sin embargo amigos la
ejecución final fue un poquito más
modesta se construyeron 59 reactores en
19 centrales diferentes pero de todos
modos es un resultado muy grande y un
objetivo sí que se consiguió francia es
tras los eeuu el país del mundo que más
energía nuclear produce y por supuesto
para francia es su mayor fuente de
generación de electricidad
[Música]
prácticamente el 70% de la electricidad
francesa es de origen nuclear el
porcentaje más alto de todo el mundo
además dada la importancia de francia en
la unión europea sus 56 reactores
operativos contribuyen notablemente a
que casi un tercio de la electricidad
consumida en el bloque comunitario sea
de origen nuclear el claro cómo es una
energía que se genera sin emitir carbono
a la atmósfera france quieres
reivindicar la energía nuclear para
luchar contra el calentamiento global
y si se lo que muchos estáis pensando
bueno bueno enrique pero también las
renovables producen electricidad sin
emitir co2 pues sí pero claro la
cuestión es que como todos sabéis la
eólica y la solar dependen de las
condiciones climáticas es decir qué pasa
por ejemplo cuando el viento no sopla
pues la respuesta a esa pregunta es algo
que hemos visto en 2021 en toda europa
cuando se ha tenido que recurrir incluso
a las fuentes de energía más sucias a
alemania- el carbón supera a la eólica
como principal fuente de electricidad
pues bien a diferencia de las renovables
la nuclear ofrece una producción de
electricidad estable y además su precio
se ve muy poquito afectado por las
fluctuaciones en el coste del uranio y
por supuesto como todos sabéis también
tienen sus inconvenientes la gestión de
los residuos nucleares es uno de ellos y
no sólo hablo de seguridad sino también
de coste por ejemplo en la propia
francia el coste del proyecto cilio un
almacén geológico profundo para los
residuos radiactivos se estima ahora en
unos 40 mil millones de euros muy lejos
de los 25 mil millones a los que
apuntaban las previsiones iniciales una
enorme inversión que sin embargo es tan
sólo la punta del iceberg
el plan messmer hizo que aproximadamente
el 80 por ciento de los reactores
nucleares franceses se construyeran
entre finales de los 70 y los años 80
con una vida útil de 40 años esto
significa que os invierte ahora en su
renovación para que continúen operando
con garantías o se debe afrontar su
desmantelamiento cualquier opción supone
para francia de cines de miles de
millones de euros
en concreto según las estimaciones de
edf el desmantelamiento de los reactores
costaría atentos unos 75 mil millones de
dólares mientras que la operación de
actualización y puesta a punto para que
las centrales puedan seguir operando
unas cuantas décadas más ascendería a
unos 50 mil millones de euros y es esta
última por la que finalmente ha apostado
el gobierno francés pero ojo porque de
momento francia tiene regulado por ley
que su capacidad nuclear no superará
nunca los 63,2 gigavatios así que es
algo cambio legislativo no previsto de
momento cualquier nuevo reactor que es
lo que al fin y al cabo ha anunciado el
presidente galo supondrá el cierre de
algún antiguo esto es algo que aún está
por definir en cualquier caso hay otra
cuestión interesante la industria
francesa ha tenido muchos muchísimos
problemas en los últimos años así que la
pregunta es realmente está preparada
para el plan macro atento
en tiempos difíciles
[Música]
si queremos hablar de energía nuclear en
francia tenemos que fijarnos sobre todo
en tres letras
efe las siglas de electricidad de france
hablamos de la empresa pública que es
dueña de las centrales nucleares
francesas y que abastece de electricidad
al país galo como si prácticamente
tuviera todo un monopolio también es
propietaria de frontón el negocio de
reactores nucleares que la compañía
absorbió en 2018 de areva otra empresa
estatal que tuvo que reestructurarse
ante los problemas que la industria
nuclear francesa ha tenido durante la
última década
el regulador nuclear de francia ordenó
en 2016 de tener 21 reactores más de un
tercio de la flota nuclear de efe
después de que reconociera defectos en
400 piezas fabricadas desde 1965 y que
eran utilizadas en los generadores de
vapor los inspectores estaban
preocupados por los altos niveles de
carbono hallados en el acero de la forja
del cree zodiac existía riesgo de
fractura en el acero en caso de un
cambio brusco de temperatura
lo que pasa entonces fue una buena
muestra de lo que podría pasar si un
buen día francia renunciará de repente a
sus centrales nucleares las centrales
térmicas se pusieron a quemar carbón a
un ritmo no visto desde la década de los
80 pero espera hace un momento porque
antes incluso que la atmósfera el
frenazo a la generación atómica lo notó
el bolsillo de los propios franceses
el precio de la luz amigo se disparó ni
más ni menos que un 40 por ciento pero
ojo porque también subió en buena parte
de los países europeos a los que francia
exporta su generación eléctrica
afortunadamente en 2017 las aguas
volvieron a su cauce pero la broma no
salió barata la estatal francesa cifró
en unos mil millones de euros el impacto
en sus cuentas del cierre y la
reparación de las plantas lo peor de
todo es que si ya este incidente es
grave de por si el gran dolor de cabeza
que todavía hoy en día atormenta edf es
el reactor europeo presurizado el pp era
un reactor de agua presurizada de
tercera generación que a principios de
siglo se presentaba como el proyecto
estrella de la industria nuclear
francesa sin embargo han pasado los años
y actualmente sólo hay dos ep en
operación están en china y uno ya ha
tenido que parar no obstante pese a todo
entre los años 2000 22 y 2023 está
previsto que empiecen a operar otros en
finlandia y también en francia
concretamente la central nuclear de flan
bill y sabéis que podría hablar de todos
los problemas que ha arrastrado el lpr
de flan bill pero qué queréis que os
diga casi mejor que os lo cuente el
ministro francés de economía
los actos de famobil tenemos que apoyar
esa construcción
juanmi
[Música]
instrucción a casa
en
definitiva fases
tal y como decía el ministro todos estos
problemas y sobrecostes han sido un duro
un durísimo golpe para la reputación de
francia en el campo de la energía
nuclear hace años por ejemplo el reino
unido- era el principal interesado en
seguir invirtiendo en energía nuclear e
instalar los cpr de la estatal francesa
las cosas hoy sin embargo son muy
diferentes si un proyecto ya está
aprobado pero como os podéis imaginar a
los british se les están quitando las
ganas de hacer más pedidos
los dos reactores se pr para ampliar la
central nuclear de un clay point se
acumulan varios años de retraso y
millones de sobrecoste su precio se ha
elevado hasta los 27 mil millones de
euros y no entrarán en servicio hasta
2026 en el aire queda la aprobación de
otros dos reactores de pdf para la
central de seis well parece que al final
se inclinarán por dar luz verde al
proyecto después de diez años de debate
por cierto precisamente el reino unido y
la rolls royce acaban de anunciar una
inversión de 400 millones de libras para
desarrollar y enseñar una nueva
generación de reactores nucleares más
pequeños hablamos de los s m&r pequeños
reactores modulares que tienen una
potencia que no superan los 300
megavatios frente por ejemplo a los más
de 1000 megavatios de los reactores
convencionales lo interesante es que
rolls-royce asegura que más pequeños
será sinónimo de menos problemas
[Música]
se espera que los sml sean más baratos y
más rápidos de construir que los
reactores existentes su coste se estima
en 2.200 millones de libras con
expectativas de reducirse en el futuro
hasta los 1.800 millones de libras los
sml están diseñados para ser producidos
en masa desde una fábrica y luego
transportados a su ubicación definitiva
su construcción que duraría entre 3 y 4
años promete ser más sencilla que la de
los reactores epr que tardan más de 10
años en ejecutarse
[Música]
y no solo es cosa del reino unido
francia también está atenta a las
evoluciones de los s mieres
[Música]
y un mes antes de anunciar la
construcción de nuevos reactores por
ejemplo macro en prometió una inversión
de mil millones de euros para el
desarrollo de estos reactores y de hecho
se ha dado cierta confusión porque
algunos medios llegaron a vincular ambos
anuncios sin embargo lo cierto es que no
están nada pero que nada claro que eso
vaya a ser así de hecho es muy probable
que el plasma chrome se corresponda más
con lo expuesto por un informe encargado
por su propio gobierno que se filtró en
un informe recomienda la construcción de
seis nuevos cpr la cuestión es que se
espera que estos seis pr previstos
cuesten un tercio menos que el pr de
flan vil y que con 50 mil millones de
euros sea suficiente para poder
construirlos todos el objetivo sería así
aprovechar las economías de escala edf
por ejemplo asegura que sus próximos 'pr
se beneficiarán de las reducciones de
costes a medida que se construye más
copias con el mismo diseño una ventaja
de la que los actuales proyectos pues no
han podido beneficiarse tampoco de la
experiencia y del aprendizaje de todos
esos errores al menos esta es la teoría
para que se haga realidad por supuesto
será muy importante la evolución
tecnológica pero especialmente que
francia tenga éxito en la batalla que
está librando en bruselas y este amigo
es otro punto clave bienvenidos a la
burocracia comunitaria
wipro
puede que no lo sepas pero la unión
europea' está a punto de tomar una
decisión vital para afrontar la lucha
contra el calentamiento global sobre la
mesa está la llamada taxonomías y
seguramente 6 muchos los que sepáis que
la taxonomía da se encarga en el mundo
de la biología de clasificar a los
animales y plantas en función de sus
características pues bien aquí lo que
pretende la comisión europea es decidir
qué fuentes de energía se clasifican
como ambientalmente sostenibles
la idea es que la taxonomía se convierta
en un principio rector para la unión
europea a la hora de decidir qué
industrias pueden ser subvencionadas
también se pretende que la taxonomía
sirva de guía para los mercados
financieros al valorar en qué fuentes de
energía merece la pena invertir por
tanto el futuro está en juego o acceso a
subsidios y capital barato o una
financiación mucho más complicada en
caso de quedar excluida
y tal y como os podéis imaginar francia
está peleando con todas sus armas sea
cara de perro para conseguir que la
energía nuclear entren los planes de
bruselas y lo más importante es que no
están solos junto a francia se han
posicionado bulgaria croacia eslovaquia
eslovenia finlandia hungría polonia
república checa y rumanía además estos
países también contaron con el apoyo de
países bajos y suecia en el último
consejo de ministros de energía hablamos
de 12 de los 27 miembros de la unión
europea pero esperad un momento porque
otros países no están ni mucho menos
dispuestos a ponerle una alfombra roja a
la energía nuclear
el grupo opositor está liderado por
alemania en 2022 culminará el apagón
nuclear que anunció tras el accidente de
fukushima luego le siguen austria
luxemburgo dinamarca portugal y también
españa y de hecho lo que está haciendo
berlín es pelear para que sea el gas
natural el que se clasifique como
ambientalmente sostenible ya que emite
menos co2 que la quema de carbón que
actualmente es una de sus principales
fuentes de energía pues bien el caso es
que la pelota está en el tejado de la
comisión europea que ha recibido un acto
delegado para definir el marco de la
taxonomía y qué demonios piensa la
comisión pues amigos amigas así se
pronuncia a finales de octubre la
presidenta ursula von der leyen es
aviesa that we need movilidad and clean
energy alonso the wind y the table
source nuclear
of wars knights huelgas antes sexuales
es mi forma de existencia
en el plan web el campo web jackson no
me propuso esta propuesta de taxonomía
se presentará como un acto delegado así
que sólo hay dos formas de que no salga
adelante que se pronuncia en contra la
mayoría del parlamento europeo o que
existe una mayoría cualificada del
consejo europeo y no aparece la tarea
nada sencilla la pregunta es estar a
bruselas realmente dispuesta a
enfrentarse a berlín
así que todo indica que nos
encontraremos con un acuerdo with pro
quo es decir algo a cambio del alemán y
acelera por un lado y francia cederá por
el otro la comisión europea de esta
forma clasificar a tanto al gas como la
nuclear como ambientalmente sostenibles
y todos contentos ya lo veis diplomacia
medite en bruselas en estado puro pero
llegado hasta aquí la pregunta es para
todos vosotros queréis que francia al
final logrará que la energía nuclear
reciba la bendición de bruselas os
gustaría que vuestro país también
pusiera en marcha un plan para construir
nuevos reactores nucleares podéis
dejarnos vuestra respuesta por aquí
abajo en los comentarios y como siempre
os digo si este vídeo se ha resultado
interesante no olvidéis darle al aek y
suscribiros a visual político un saludo
y hasta la próxima
[Música]